you had a Super Bowl ad not many people
can say they had a Super Bowl ad and I
liked your Super Bowl ad I'm glad you
did yeah yeah it was really kind of
unusual little bizarre wasn't it it was
a strange it sort of came out of nowhere
let's run your Super Bowl ad and we'll
talk about it
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
okay I actually find that a little
offended a little scary when I thought
it was happening it scared me mm-hmm
I've woken up several times in my life
and you've been doing that if my bad
creeped into people's windows and do
that I go Santa Claus that is for
something called the sleep tapes is that
right leapin tapes yeah Squarespace this
website design company came to me with
this idea
they got this an agency-wide and Kennedy
to come up with this bizarre thing where
it wasn't just an ad for the website
they said no we want to show the folks
that no matter how crazy your idea is it
could make a beautiful website so kind
jeff we'd like to entice you to make an
absurd website and man we just had a
ball doing it and then the clincher of
the whole thing for me was that all the
sales from the downloads and from the
album's all goes to share our strengths
no Kid Hungry campaign
[Applause]
you